if I read a script that I feel like
hella I gotta get okay
if I read it if I read whenever you
descripted I feel like is a story or a
role that is something I have to do or I
want to be a part of it's a feeling of
like claustrophobia or pressure at first
and like a feeling of that I need to be
a part of it and then thinking you know
what the audition process going to be
and and how do I get as close to this
goal as possible because as we all know
the answer is more often know than it is
a yes but you know I said this to a
friend recently like getting very close
to a role or getting a lot of callbacks
or being one of the last three but then
not getting it that is not a clear loss
there's a feeling of an overnight switch
with some of these films but it's been
an even more gratifying feeling as we're
working with producers or directors that
I work with before in the past and more
than anything more than a one random
successful audition I think just as
consistently putting out as much good
work as possible in audition form and
casting form is a step in the right
direction I think honesty and being as
open a book as possible I think that was
the biggest takeaway from the drama high
school I went to for me was keep your
heart in the sleeve as an actor that's
your instrument your ability to make
yourself an open wound is what will
communicate to the audience and
hopefully serve as a therapeutic device
for people experience something
experiencing something similar to the
story I think that's true of call me by
our name and we just did the interview
with Daniel Kuya and I think it's true
of get out as well as it relates to
working more professionally and outside
of a academically dramatic environment I
think it's adaptability that's like the
strongest suit you can have as an actor
the experience working with Luca
Guadagnino is different than the
experience working with Greta Gerwig was
different from the experience working
with Christopher Nolan and as an actor
particularly if you're not the leader of
the project you try to make yourself as
clay-like as malleable as possible I'm
flipping the radar a Wallflower somebody
who comes prepared and is ready to go
and maybe have an idea or trick up your
sleeve something you want to try out but
ultimately responsibilities to the
characters or the story to that sequin
that day and just trying to do them
myself as possible playing Elio he is
kind of a Renaissance teenager no way
what was your research process in Tim
did you read the book and also kind of
you don't remember the eighties but your
experience of being a teenager in the
80s it's so nuanced in particular which
you know it's captured so well oh right
well how did you go back oh yeah like
you said it's the the book the book
becomes like a Bible of sorts and for
those that have read the book it's
fiercely from the point of view of Ellie
oh so there's just so much to pull from
and there's there's a lot of background
information and then as you you know
point it out to there's a lot of piano
playing and I have to learn Italian for
that too so there was a you know about a
month and a half two months of a
background research going into it and
anybody can it's time to do it you just
try to let that all go and do the best
job you can I think uh now in the method
II sense I don't think a relationship
has to mirror what's on screen
necessarily but I think if your
characters don't know one another that
could be helpful to have a garden miss
or an awkwardness or a wall present in
the scene but if you're working with
someone intimately it's good to have
that chemistry just from a perspective
of you know wanting to try things out as
an actor and feeling comfortable not
feeling like the person opposite you is
gonna be judging you which can sound
silly or something but you know it's a
game of sensitivity and more sensitive
you can make yourselves and work more
able to communicate usually so comforts
important and and also I think of
working relationship and and you know
the hopefully the emotional IQ and to
know when to step away if you're seeing
partners having a tough time of things
or know when a word of encouragement can
be used knowing what not to say but
ultimately trying to be the greatest
ensemble member as possible keeping in
mind that it's a marathon and not a
sprint and particularly if you are one
of the leads on a project they you know
you're a tone setter of sorts so you
can't exclusively be concerned about
your performance and actually often your
performance is aided if you can put your
collective conscious on somebody else in
the scene or on the story or on the
script and not
you know what's happening to that line
or what inflection you want to use or
what have you that's what makes me want
to be an artist that's what makes me
want to be an actor it's that feeling of
flow and like I heard someone say to me
once before like he can be stapling
papers or it can be playing the piano or
it could be acting I think when you lose
yourself when you find that certain
feeling that's exciting and more
exciting than you know being at home
eight hours before you do the scene and
thinking that's the scene that I that I
feel that climax and lose myself in but
rather you know you're in the middle the
scene and and in no cheesy way but just
feeling like oh I don't know what
happened there that was truth floors or
spontaneous and and working from that
perspective which is admittedly easier
the more you work because like I
remember like Craig gelati who directed
I Tanya he put me in my first pilot ever
in one of my first jobs I remember the
audition I had for him I think I had
three lines and like a three-page scene
so I don't really have much to say as a
family scene I memorized where each
family member in the room was so in this
audition my neck was stepping around you
know for the first couple takes you like
you know you just look at the reader and
you know keep pretending there are
people everywhere so like I you know you
know them starting outside like I would
want to know exactly what I was doing in
advance and and memorize the other
dialogue and scene and what other people
were doing I could see when mr. Perlman
at the end of calling by her name is a
huge speech and I usually really like to
know what the posting dialog is just for
a rhythm of the scene and to know the
pacing but that was one right you know I
think I knew maybe wouldn't women's last
lines were but I really wanted to
experience it and hear it on the day and
have a natural moment with it and not
not know exactly what was coming
I think you see with people that have
messed with four-d or in the past smell
activation or even Kanye West the Cannes
Film Festival set up seven screens a
couple years ago and with the emergence
of VR there's so many directions it can
go but if you see like the that the IMAX
gatekeepers are gatekeepers simply
because they have the keys I don't know
they're people that will be restraining
change but also those that will be
entitled to point in what direction it
goes will be in positions of power so
hopefully it'll be organic we'll see
last year in a way surprised to have
your lives changed dramatically in kind
of the last 12 months with the success
of these two films yes yeah like what
I'm really grateful for was calling my
name and I can I don't I'd be cruces is
the experience on get out I remember
being in New York when get out came out
and it really it was like an explosion
like everyone was so excited to see in
the posters were everywhere and the
great thing is like I haven't had the
total destabilizing experience I think
you can read an interview sometimes
other people where it's really like an
overnight switch or something and what's
amazing is like when I see people or
people stopped in the street or I've
seen you a couple times that's it's
always it's it hasn't been oh you're in
that show you're in that movie it's oh
you're in calling me by our name which
is a book that really means the world to
me
so that's I mean you dream about that as
an art it's really like that's that's
been really nice for me to experience
because I have seen people I've admired
in interviews maybe not be so
comfortable with that but I'm like I
enjoyed it
Jax is like you know but they were the
Booker they like the movie have you seen
them she's in London the last time let's
see
[Laughter]
the fingers I'm trying I hide in it you
tell me you can come back to winning the
first time ever get out no I just yeah
you can go home you can go I can go home
like because I went back to the estate
so I was like yeah okay my what I mean
and then I'd you just get I just I
always hide in it I go like I never I
just don't really want to engage in it I
just I like and then so like now I think
it's probably going mad in their lane
and I'm here so it's great so you kind
of you're kind of because I don't know
how my life's changed because it hasn't
it's gone up a notch it keeps on going
up a notch and you don't know what is
the new new normal now you know and my
premiums were here this is like this has
been the great thing about having a
friendship with Daniel is all these
stops we've been doing I don't feel like
I relate to any very few people in the
room but I can always lock eyes with
Daniel you've obviously that you both
made some really interesting very clever
choices to be fair in the films you've
done you know with Lady Bird and call
you by your no pants they get out right
Panther yeah
[Applause]
are you nervous about kind of what
you're gonna accept and what you're
going to do next is you sorry level now
of expectation that Wow well there's a
get get out universe and claim our name
universe refusing and nobody like that
okay no I mean mmm yes or no I mean
again this feels like ah you know I I'm
very young and yet there have been a lot
of auditions that are knows and meetings
that are knows and projects you're a
part of they get made but aren't
necessarily well received so this feels
like appreciation time and just maybe
two weeks left of having this nice kind
of moment so what comes from there will
be great I know I find the one thing I
keep in my mind is like hey you know
have this you know respect the respect
the reception if that makes any sense
and you know you you have to try and be
in the pedigree of lady burger calling
our name or get out you can't you know
you can't solve that out Daniel do you
think you'll go back to writing that's
not been doing that's what I'm trying to
do and yeah it's just gotten mad like
yeah no that's what I'm writing a
feature in a film so I've been doing
that more than acting that's what's
quite surreal for me it's kind of like
like all this is I just made a couple
decisions
oh yeah I did I do that an initial at
all and because I was just kind of was
like oh man like I just felt this urge
to like to write and I got loads of
ideas that I want to like make and and
you just have to put the hours in
because you read them and it got it's
just [ __ ] like you're like I mean you
just have to put there's no shortcut you
have to put yeah I mean you don't want
this you've got you want a long cut the
long cut is always more interesting so
you have to just do the work so yeah
like that's that's kind of where my my
head where I'm where I'm heading in
India and the thing you're writing is
are a part for a young skinny
now you got bone cut bro myself it would
be I don't know I think it's a it's a
lesson that I feel like I learned early
on but it's one that I try to keep as
personal as possible I don't think it's
exclusive to entertainment and to to
filmmaking I think it's in any
collaborative process that it's often
not personal a negative note someone
being brash in the way they're giving
you a note it's your it's a team effort
so there's because like I said you want
to keep yourself open and sensitive when
you're working at least I try to but you
have to and I can be this can be not I
feel like a parent at a young age but
there has to be like professional you
work you thick-skinned ready to get
whatever note really comes at you and
then there's personal here which you
protect and helps you protect the work
you and I think you keep those things
separate and I guess that was I had a
good year in drama high score I felt
like I did a scene poorly a number of
times where I feel like I can get over
being bad and yet before that I was
really like a very very sensitive about
performance and notes and and would take
things personally when really I mean the
whole point and the tension as an actor
is you know your body your voice your
physicality is your instrument and yet
it's not personal somebody gives you a
note or you're not clicking you're not
getting you see in a certain way
[Music]